une énième mais aventure qui l'a poussé
à franchir la porte d'un commissariat
coralie rivière jeunes handicapés de 19
ans a décidé de porter plainte contre
keolis et fil bleu une première à tour
en cause des problèmes récurrents
qu'elle rencontre pour prendre le bus et
son cas ne serait pas isolé plus
d'explications dans ce reportage de sa
malle colin
à 19 ans coralie ne peut plus passer de
son fauteuil roulant à cause d'une
maladie génétique évolutive pour se
déplacer elle prend le bus quand elle ne
se fait pas et conduire par le chauffeur
comme par exemple samedi dernier
les bornes à verre en ville avec une
amie et ben c'est à millas voulait
monter dans le bus allait voir le
chauffeur le sauveur et des
conséquences attendre le temps pour ses
parents de contacter d'abord un taxi
avant de se résoudre à venir la chercher
place jean jaurès elle a attendu une
heure et quart sur le trottoir devant la
mairie des rampes qui ne fonctionne pas
des chauffeurs qui refuse de la laisser
monter en deux ans et situation
difficile à accepter pour la jeune fille
se répète le dernier épisode en date la
pousse à porter plainte pour
discrimination contre keolis est bien
possible de laisser un monde de gabès
sur un trottoir c'est pas c'est parce
qu'ils ont dans la tête il ya des
personnes en fauteuil roulant qui
veulent pas battre mais messi en fait
ses parents eux se retrouvent démunis et
déplore un service de bus aux abonnés
absents première fois qu'on passe dessus
je dirais une table ça arrive à tout le
monde mais là quand c est régulier
et pratiquement bas quant à chaque fois
qu avait à tour nous on compte sur le
service public une solution pourrait
être fil blanc un transport à la demande
et en porte à porte pour les personnes
en situation de handicap mais il faut le
réserver 48 heures en avance des usagers
en fauteuil laissé sur le bord de la
route ce n'est pas une généralité
même si cela arrive pour cette
association
moi c'est ce que j'entends également de
certains adhérents qui me disent
effectivement que ça fonctionne pas si
bien que ça quelques fois alors certains
me disent c'est parce qu'il les utilise
pas assez souvent et que ces grippes et
je suis pas sûr que ce soit ça je pense
qu'il ya de la mauvaise volonté de
certains chauffeurs certainement de son
côté fil bleu ne souhaite pas
communiquer et assure que les nouveaux
bus déployés à la fin de l'année auront
de nouvelles rampes électriques
débrayable manuellement en cas de panne
et la place suffisante pour accepter
deux fauteuils roulants dans le bus